for more on the Lakers well Mark LeBron
James vowed after their game five loss
I'll be better in game six and with just
a day off between games and the Lakers
had a personal day yesterday today
though he arrived around 2PM was out on
the court getting shots up by himself
starting around 2 20. he typically
arrives at the arena at 2 30 or so on
game days but it's not typical for him
to be out on the court that early and he
didn't have any music solo with
assistant coaches just focused and I
asked him pre-game how you feeling and
you just gave me a head knife LeBron
understands the mentality of closeout
games more than anyone and has shown
that today this series marks the 17th
time LeBron's career his team has taken
3-1 lead in the 16 prior instances
LeBron won the series of five or six
games and he's on his way to making it a
perfect 17 for 17 tonight guys
[Applause]
incredible list of players that he's up
there with and closing in on deep issues
here at the game tonight
[Applause]
and right now gonna
sit out these last nine minutes plus